[Aplausos]
[Música]
pues yo estoy muy emocionado porque esta
tarde
quiero compartirles cuatro pilares que
han dado certeza y finitud
a mi futuro
cuatro pilares
y espero le den certeza
y éxito a tu futuro sea si tú lo quieres
independientemente de la adversidad
independientemente de la escuela
cuando tenía más o menos 15 años
y mi papá me invitó a su trabajo
y me invitó a su oficina había una
sillita me senté y allí al lado del
escritorio y me regaló un cuadernito
cuadernito chiquito que estaba
estaba vacío era de estos cuadernillos
que tenían una hoja de cada día de la
semana como un diario y tenían unas
memorias en la parte de abajo cuando lo
abro
[Música]
está un poema un poema que aparte me
llamó muchísimo la atención porque
estaba subrayado
y lo leí ese poema era de amado nervo no
sé si alguno de ustedes ha escuchado a
amado nervo es un poeta un escritor muy
exitoso latinoamericano es mexicano
y el poema que estaba ahí era de en paz
vida estamos en paz
lo leí completito no se los voy a leer
esta tarde pero sí quiero leerles y
compartirles un párrafo que para mí ha
sido fundamental un párrafo que a mí me
ha llenado de energía
veo al final de mi rudo camino que yo
fui el arquitecto de mi propio destino
que se extraje las hieles o la miel de
las cosas
fue porque en ellas puse jr
oye las preciosas
plante rosales los hechos siempre rosas
ese poema lo había subrayado a mi mamá
y recuerdo que es cuando mi mamá
falleció en la misa de cuerpo presente
pidió que lo leyera
y no es una plática para hacerlos llorar
ahora que ese no es mi intención
lo que quiero es motivarlos ss para mí
fue un símbolo mi mamá quería
agradecerle a la vida por su vida por su
obra que dejó
por lo que hizo en vida
y eso es lo que le ha dado fundamento a
estos cuatro pilares que hoy yo te
quiero compartir
el primero
y todo obstáculo puede ser el trampolín
de tu vida todo obstáculo es el
trampolín de mi vida cualquier
adversidad
por difícil que esté
de ser el trampolín de tu vida cuando yo
tenía estaba en quinto de primaria tenía
diez años
yo estaba en el salón de clases ya se
haya acabado el ciclo escolar y
estábamos todos esperando las boletas
finales
quería que las entregara
benigno alfaro soy el primero en la
lista y yo por favor que se haya
equivocado no vengo al faro me entregan
la boleta y mis nervios
es cuando leo había reprobado el año
a los 10 años ese fue el primer y más
grande fracaso en mi vida
en ese momento
pues yo me estaba alejado de mis amigos
yo los estaba perdiendo
yo no podía continuar con ellos el
siguiente nivel la mayoría de los
profesores le decían a mis papás benigno
ven y no no se puede concentrar mínimo
no retiene le cuesta muchísimo trabajo
estar en esta escuela
el idioma el alemán estaba el colegio
alemán guadalajara no no ni por aquí no
le entran
parece que tiene as lines en los
calzones no se puede controlar
eso ahora y después de muchos años en
ese entonces no existía pero han
estudiado y eso se llama déficit de
atención hoy en día es una enfermedad es
una condición y se tacha muchos niños y
les dice no tú no vas a poder tú no vas
a poder ser exitoso
no te puedes concentrar
y le dijeron a mis papás a lo mejor le
recomendamos que lo manden a una escuela
especial
sí sí es muy bueno para el deporte sí es
bueno para la clase de música si es
bueno para artísticas
pero no son materias tan importantes
[Música]
la verdad es que yo me ese problema un
monstruo
enorme estaba perdiendo uno de los
valores más grandes que yo tenía en ese
momento y en la mayoría de mis amigos
y posiblemente iba a salir de la escuela
platicando con mis papás
analizando la situación
pudimos y seccionar este gran monstruo y
este gran monstruo eran dos problemas
principalmente uno el déficit de
atención no se puede enfocar enfoque y
el segundo alemán
no sencillo
entonces qué pasó pues el enfoque lo
empecé a trabajar
y me metieron a cualquier cantidad de
deportes el deporte te permite
concentrarte de manera aguda en ciertos
momentos te tira la pelota estás
viéndola y estás concentradísimo en las
sillas
música te permite también yo les pongo
un rato a un niño de déficit de atención
que le guste la música y darle si está
tomando clases una flauta que se grabe
una melodía se va a enfocar en toda la
tarde va a estar a dieta
fijados para sacar a ese menor
lo que me enseñó ese es ese momento es
que los problemas
son tan grandes como los vemos
y tú puedes enfrentarlos un problema no
lo vas a evitar
y lo vas a tener siempre en tu vida
vendrán muchísimos el tema es como los
analistas como los disección las
también como tú actúas ante ellos te
puedes hacer más grande tú que ese
problema
[Música]
el segundo
alguien de ustedes ha visto esta
caricatura saben quién es este chico no
si por allá bueno ya no estoy tan rico
la verdad es que ya me siento así que sé
que estamos ayer gente contemporánea
aquí que cada visto sport bild sport
billy es un niño de atenas
y los dioses le dieron una maleta y en
esa maleta le dieron los dioses todos
los accesorios deportivos que necesitase
ese niño ese chico para cualquier
adversidad en su infancia
entonces portil y metía la mano allí y
se acaba todas las herramientas para
poder sortear cualquier problema
cuando yo estaba a punto de entrar a la
universidad mi papá se acerca y me dice
no va a poder preparar la universidad la
crisis del 94 le ha pegado duro a la
familia mi papá perdió su negocio y no
me podía pagar la universidad y cuando
me dice esto me cayeron varios 20s y me
puse actual
y yo no puedo ser una carga para mi papá
es una universidad cara si yo quiero
estar aquí lo tengo que sacar con los
propios medios y ahí fue cuando empecé
a analizar
caja de herramientas y herramientas
tengo yo hoy que puedan hacer quiero
estudiar en esa universidad si soy bueno
para el fútbol beca deportiva aplique
para una beca deportiva me dieron un
porcentaje
pues con mi papá durante la secundaria
del prep estuve trabajando ya lo mejor
en el departamento de relaciones
públicas de la universidad ocupan
becarios fui me becaron le dieron otro
porcentaje me hacía falta un piquito
arranque mi primer emprendedurismo la
primera una carpintería arte rústico con
dos de mis mejores amigos de la
universidad
lo que quiero decir es que si quieres
ser bueno en algo si quieres ser el
mejor te tienes que rodear de los
mejores instrumentos las herramientas
son importantísimas en tu vida para
sortear cualquier obstáculo
quiero ser empresario tengo que saber
cómo leer un modelo de negocios estados
financieros contabilidad finanzas áreas
funcionales
y rodearme de los mejores tener un gran
equipo de trabajo
juntarme con emprendedores que tengan la
misma vibra que yo esa es una
herramienta de trabajo no lo más técnico
y experiencias de experiencias de vida
sobre eso
la tercera visión clara y atractiva
cuando estaba
por entrar a la universidad y ya había
afortunadamente logrado definir cuál era
mi pasión y quería ser empresario
eso ya lo tenía clarísimo y fui
adornando la idea para darle muchísima
diversidad atractivo y que simplemente
el hecho de pensarlo me motivará pero
esto no se hubiera dado si no hubiese
descartado mis otras dos pasiones que
también me impulsaba la vida yo quería
ser uno sánchez para un jugador de
fútbol porque no quiere ser mes y ahora
no
pero yo quería hacer uno sánchez y la
universidad y la vida también buscándole
me dio la oportunidad de descartar esa
pasión el fútbol lo vivía al máximo me
pague a la universidad haciéndolo todos
los días se entrenaba había días que
entrenaba hasta dos veces llevamos los
fines de semana a jugar a pueblos y
jugué semiprofesional saben que es una
de mis grandes pasiones pero no me
quiero dedicar a eso el resto de mi vida
yo lo supe lo supe en ese momento y la
segunda pasión los caballos adoro los
caballos montar a caballo me encanta
tuve la oportunidad de preparatoria
dedicarme profesionalmente a los
caballos mis papás no querían que estaba
loco de cómo era posible pero era una de
mis grandes pasiones de salida de la
preparatoria y se trepa abierta y me
dedique profesionalmente a los caballos
tres años
y me pasó exactamente lo mismo es uno de
mis grandes hobbies y es una pasión que
voy a seguir haciendo pero no quiero ser
profesional y el resto de unidades
carnes
quiero decir es que tienes que tener una
visión clara asertiva y que te motive
la última es tomar acción
fui a la última reunión de ex alumnos de
la universidad digo del colegio alemán y
me dicen mis compañeros uno de ellos
medición y beni
como es que de plano sin hacer más burro
del salón ahora tienes
tienes ahora
un grupo educativo que son 8 empresas
están en estos países
tienes la primera financiera educativa
en méxico
las estructuras del negocio familiar
la neta no me halle
[Música]
y entonces le digo por muy claro la
visión la tenía súper clara
tome acción ya
cuando entré a la universidad yo sabía
que quería ser empresario lo que lo que
tenía que hacer era prepararme y
entonces no dude y louis i formiguera en
convicción todas las decisiones que he
tomado a raíz de eso de que tenía clara
esa visión han sido para prepararme y
para poder hacer empresa para poder ser
empresario
a mis 42 años bueno ya 3 la semana
pasada en un antepasado
después de 33 años
[Música]
le quiero dar gracias a la vida
le quiero dar gracias a la vida porque
me enseñó
y ese problema de tener aquí lines en
los calzones
y déficit de atención
ha sido uno de los más grandes
trampolines de mi vida y sólo prometía
el día de hoy aquí con ustedes de tal
manera que hoy
yo quiero regalarles esta hornilla
yo quiero regalarles esta hormiga
y que la utilice siempre y cuando tengan
su visión clara se preparen y tengan
herramientas tengan una actitud ante los
problemas del miedo
y entonces si agarran las hormiguitas y
se la pongan en los calzones muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah